school shooting in South Florida 17
people shot to death what can be done
about school shootings some say kids
will be safer if some teachers carry
guns President Trump said that we need
to let people know you come into our
schools you're gonna be dead
Trump was mocked for suggesting teachers
have guns armed a teacher is completely
insane it's a terrible idea a terrible
idea but critics probably don't even
know that many teachers have brought
guns to school for years in Texas
teachers carry in about 200 schools this
high school advertises that I can see
that sign out on the highway boy it's a
great man parents we interviewed here
like the policy it's a good idea I think
we need it
it makes me feel safer I love the Keene
gun policy Superintendent Ricky Stephens
created it saying if there's trouble
teachers want to go defend the kids we
know our staff and our teachers are
gonna go do we want them to go with a
pencil I'll go with a pistol everybody's
against it this Florida student says
teachers carrying guns is a terrible
idea you're asking a teacher to fight an
assault rifle with a handgun that seems
like a pretty unfair fight to me the
teachers have handguns against somebody
with a big gun that's not much it's not
much but it's better than nothing if you
go there with nothing you have no chance
of stopping anything the police come
they see your teacher with a gun how do
you keep them from shooting her we train
a lot with our local law enforcement so
that helps us because we want them to at
least know where they're and at least
recognize us if they happen to get shot
while they're stopping a tragedy all of
our Gardens have said you know that's
just the price of being a guardian his
teacher saw how during the Florida
school shooting the security guard
waited outside maybe mad it's a reason
she's glad she can carry her gun at
school you have to have a fighting
chance that something should happen at
our school we hid her identity because
she and the school don't want a
potential attacker to know which
teachers are armed
are you carrying now
of course many people say armed teachers
create new dangers teacher accidentally
fired a gun in his classroom at this
California school teacher mistakenly
shot at the ceiling one student was
slightly hurt by falling debris but
that's the only incident we could find
where a student was injured took a rifle
- on the other hand armed teachers have
stopped school shootings
sixteen-year-old Luke Woodham has been
arrested when this student killed two
classmates an assistant principal with a
gun held the killer at gunpoint until
police arrived we don't know how often
armed teachers deter shootings the media
can't cover crimes that never happened
the media also distort what President
Trump proposed Donald Trump said
teachers should have guns teachers
should not be required to protect and
serve and to teach required no teachers
required to carry its voluntary those
who want to bring their guns to school
can't
here's another Distortion I really do
not support the idea of arming teachers
arming teachers arming teachers a new
federal program that's not what the
president proposed lots of teachers
already have guns all the school has to
do is allow some to bring their guns to
school at the Keene school district
however superintendent Stevens did
create a new government program the
school purchases a gun and then they we
give them and register them to our
teachers that way he says he can make
sure all teachers have training on the
same type of gun finally as we ponder
the best way to keep students safe we
should address the scariest myth
epidemic shootings epidemic of school
shootings despite what the media say
there is no epidemic of school shootings
no sharp increase school shootings kill
far fewer kids than driving suicide
drowning even suffocating why now school
shootings are not in a big uptick
exactly right but we prepare for them
because if even one shooting happens
it's more than we would want you're ten
times as likely to die suffocating right
can't protect against all these things
no but we do train our kids in school
how to not suffocate how not to drown
certainly Stephens armed teacher
programs cheaper than what my town does
New York City spends hundreds of
millions of dollars stationing police
officers in and around schools of course
here and in most blue states suggesting
that some teachers carry weapons
horrifies people they don't understand
that a responsible trained teacher with
a firearm is better than having a
teacher with nothing Texas will
definitely probably be leading the way
when it comes to protecting our kids
with weapons and that New York would
choose to go a radically different way
I'm glad that we live in a country where
the local people can decide what goes on
in their school district and not a bunch
of people in New York City it's good
that America has 50 states that allows
experiments teachers in New York City
may fear guns but teachers in Texas can
serve and protect